apropos junge menschen da stehen gerade
zwei vor allen dingen im fokus die
gerade die neuen chefs der grünen jugend
geworden sind herr lambsdorff und einer
hat sich da in der vergangenheit recht
heftig gegen ihren vorsitzenden geäußert
wie christian lindner fand ihn jetzt
nicht den allergrößten sympathien bisher
sondern sagt der ist ein rechter
kotzbrocken es hat er damals muss man
ein bisschen einordnen auf die thüringen
wahl und den ganz ganz vorübergehenden
erfolg von thomas kemmerich dort im land
gemünzt aber sprechen von einem rechten
kotzbrocken damals und nennt ihnen die
gelbe 0 und einfach widerlich usw das
sind ältere tweets von ihm aber das
entspricht offenbar seiner
geisteshaltung das sind auch leute auf
die sie aktuell zielen herr graf
lambsdorff also auf die jungen leute und
die die am ende mit wie beim
koalitionsvertrag entscheiden
was ist jetzt die frage ob sie sich
freuen auf die zusammenarbeit mit all
denen die
wissen wir wissen ja dass wir von
unterschiedlichen perspektiven kommen
dass wir auf dem die ziele hat frau
brandner gerade beschrieben aber die
wege zu den zielen die definieren wir
durchaus unterschiedlich und da gibt es
natürlich auch hin und wieder mal eine
antipathie ich will dein sehen uns da
gar nicht irgendwie in schutz nehmen
oder sagen dass ich mich ja darauf freut
mit ihnen zusammenzuarbeiten und wir
schauen einfach mal wie das ganze jetzt
klappen wird wir fangen jetzt an mit den
richtigen sondierungen und dann werden
wir am ende der woche sozusagen schauen
wo wir stehen ich bin optimistisch dass
es klappt weil ich kann nur eines sagen
meine zusammenarbeit mit frau brandi
datiert schon aufs europaparlament
zurück wir kommen prima miteinander aus
das bild für viele kollegen von den
grünen genauso und umgekehrt glaube ich
ist es auch gelungen in den gesprächen
jetzt eine gute vertrauensbasis für die
nächsten gespräche zu schaffen deswegen
solche äußerungen aus dem zusammenhang
gerissen ein zusammenhang nicht ja sagen
wir sind ja eigentlich ja aber aber aber
nicht wie ich muss
[Musik]